I'm like man, I haven't done
a good enough job clarifying
that when I talk about work ethic,
I'm trying to speak to
people who are unhappy
or complaining.
If I can get people to
think about their careers
the way they feel about
waking up in the morning
and running for that hour,
where they clear their
stress, they love it.
I hate running, so that
doesn't work for me.
But like, for me,
working is the happy place.
And I want that for everybody
because the big thing
is I don't think people really quantified
how many hours of their adult life
is actually working.
Like, think about how much
work takes up the time that you are awake.
So a lot of people are like,
"Oh, I work nine hours a day."
I'm like, yeah but you also
sleep nine hours a day.
So that means, you work nine hours a day
and then everything else you do
while you're awake is only six hours.
Travel, shower, like work
is a lot of your life.
F*** man, do I want
you to want to like it,
and live it, and like enjoy it.
It's a lot dude
- Yeah.
- Like even if you work nine to five.
If you work eight hours a day,
and you sleep eight hours a day,
that means work is fifty percent
of every hour of your whole day.
For, forty years of your life.
Like, why the f*** are you
doing something you hate?
Make less money, buy less fancy s***,
and be happy.
Like, literally people are
miserable because of an
extra room in their house.
- I think it's the comfort, though.
People are comfortable, they don't want
to change it up.
- Yeah, but you know what?
I think it's the people
buying s*** they don't need,
and then have to work a job they hate
to pay for the s*** they don't need.
- To impress people they don't like.
(slams hand)
- I hate that s***.
It f***s me heavy.
Which is how I got to the Jones'.
Which is how I got to don't worry about
other people's judgment.
The other thing is,
if you're twenty-two, eighteen,
twenty-five, thirty and you think
you should have your
whole life figured out?
That's ludicrous.
I think self-awareness,
if you are capable of accepting yourself
for who you are,
is actually the brightest light of it all.
I love being self aware.
I suck at a lot of things.
I just don't think about them.
Like, I can't read for s***.
I interrupt people when I interview them
24/7 everybody's super
pissed on the internet
about that, not good.
There's plenty of things
that I'm not good at.
I love self-awareness, I like-
It's kept me so happy.
You know, I'm not upset at myself
that I'm selfish in certain areas.
That's human.
I think that we just
don't love each other,
ourselves, enough.
I don't know whose
perfection I'm trying to live up to.
Like, silly things, like people
get on me for biting my nails.
Gives a f***?
Like people are just critiquing
themselves all day long.
Like the sheer unhappiness
that I see on a day to day basis
because somebody else's opinion
is dragging you down.
- And they let people
continue to terrorize.
- A hundred percent.
And honestly,
it's a game of other people's opinions.
Whether that's the anonymous comment.
Whether that's your friend
who thinks you're selling out
after like you've popped a little bit.
Whether that's...
I mean for me it goes deep
like I can't hear anybody at this point.
And I think when people hear that,
it can go into audacity and delusion.
And I respect that, I think it's a
I think I walk a very tight rope.
And I don't think on every day,
I'm always at my best.
I'm sure sometimes I'm
delusional or audacious.
But it sure beats being crippled
by everybody's opinions
on an hourly basis.
Which is the f***ing masses.
I'm big on
squeezing as hard as you can
when you're on the field.
I love sports, I think a lot about it.
I'd be such a son of a b**** on the field,
but as soon as pssh, game over
I'd be like yo give daps and like.
But like, when I'm on the field I'm hard.
So like, I want people to sleep.
Sleep eight hours a day.
Talk to me about the
sixteen hours you're awake.
People like, "Yo' I don't sleep."
I'm like no that's not cool,
that's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying, when you're
awake for seventeen hours.
Like if you sleep four hours a day,
but you watch three hours
a day of f***ing YouTube.
You're a f***ing idiot.
Like sleep seven hours and
make your f***ing work.
Like it's quality and quantity,
but it all comes down to
to answer your question directly,
it comes down to who you are.
It's become very obvious to me
that excuses are my poison.
And I want to eliminate them at all costs.
I talk a lot about hustle and hard work,
and people are kind of pushing back
on me a little bit right now.
And it's been interesting,
I'm like man, I haven't done
a good enough job clarifying
that when I talk about work ethic,
I'm trying to speak to
people who are unhappy
or complaining.
Not happy with your job?
Don't watch Netflix,
work after hours, save money, quit.
I'm not trying to get people
into depression or burnout.
I'm trying to address unhappiness.
Like, if you complain and you're unhappy
I will spend my career suffocating
the living s*** out of you.
So, you know, like the
answer to your question,
whatever the f*** makes
you happy at that point.
And if you're at twenty-six right now
and you need to prove to the world,
and most importantly yourself,
that you're gonna f***ing do it.
Like, f***ing work every
minute of the holidays.
If you are thirty one and you've worked
seven years of your life to get to a place
and you just had your first child,
go f***ing spend three
weeks and see every relative
so they can rub little Johnny's head.
Like, I don't give a f***.
I don't have a point of view.
My point of view is know yourself,
figure yourself out, and don't do it
for anybody else.
It's real.
- Yeah.
- It's very real. Who you trying to-
I hate when people like,
"Yo' Garry B. Been on a
bender nine days in a row.
Haven't f***ing slept."
I reply all the time like
don't do it for me.
And definitely f***ing sleep.
- (laughs)
Like you know, I just-
For me, the thing that's going to allow me
to win the next half century,
and this is just the beginning
and I will not burn out like people
are waiting for me to do, is I'm happy.
People are confused.
I hate that people are pushing
too hard against hard work right now.
It's ideological, hard work
is part of the equation.
I hate when people work
hard for ten, fifteen years,
make a lot of money,
and then start telling
everybody else to just sleep and meditate.
- Yeah, get out. Yeah.
- I'm like cool, but don't
be f***ing ideological.
Like tell your truth.
Like you worked.
So, like, now you made
it and you're a big shot.
Like, be careful. Don't be a hypocrite.
To have micro losses, is actually
a very big part of
being an all-time great.
Because the success is the game itself.
Back to the process.
- Yup.
You know, like I don't need the W's.
I like the L's, I like the W's.
I put myself in a position to lose fights.
And I think a lot of the people that
are not going to win to their capability,
are scared to go into the ring
against a worthy opponent. And-
- They'd rather not try
just so they don't fail.
- Because they worry about
other people's opinions.
I'm telling you, man,
it's crazy to be at this place in my life
where I'm like, f*** this all synthesizes
down to people worrying about
other people's opinions."
And, "Oh s***! That's why
I didn't do bad things
in high school that my
mom asked me not to do."
Because not the prettiest girl in school,
and not the biggest jock,
and not the coolest kids,
none of their voices penetrated my dome.
I'm looking for people who are happy.
Like, I'm obsessed with my process.
And I just, I wish people
loved their game, their process.
People that are obsessed with the process
not the s*** that the
f***ing game buys you.
- Not the cars, not the shoes,
but the actual process.
- Because then you're finished, right?
Like if you actually want the-
if you want from the off whites
to the f***ing mansion
to the private planes
to the spa treatments to the girls
to the red carpet to
the dresses and gowns,
the jewelry.
Then, you don't have a long career.
But if you can't breathe...
Like, that is why entrepreneurship
is so weird to me.
I so couldn't breathe
that I wasn't even capable
of getting C's in high school
because I would suffocate giving school
even another second of not me being
in my own head of how to
sell wine or baseball cards.
People who can't breathe if
they're not doing their art.
And for me business is my art,
and for other people it's art,
other people it's designing,
other people it's performing on stage.
I need somebody who's
obsessed with their craft
and would be doing it
for "free" quote unquote.
- No matter what.
I'm telling you, man,
it's crazy to be at this place in my life
where I'm like, f*** this all synthesizes
down to people worrying about
other people's opinions.
And, "Oh s***! That's why
I didn't do bad things
in high school that my
mom asked me not to do."
Because not the prettiest girl in school,
and not the biggest jock,
and not the coolest kids,
none of their voices penetrated my dome.
So if I can get through high school,
real life's easy.
(Inspirational music)
It's f***ing happy.
Making so much happen,
it just feels exactly right.
Vlog, I love!
Thank you so much for watching this s***.
This journey means a lot,
the feedback, the comments, subscribe
if you haven't, please!